Peevy
can you hear me good good all the way in
the back okay all right you can all be
seated now we got a few stragglers
coming in that's low right so my name is
Stefan Boatwright I am a representative
of the left forum board it is my job to
welcome you to left forum 2016 thank you
all for coming
you're sure that this is going to be a
wonderful forum I attended my first
forum in 2010 just like many of you as a
spectator it was a really amazing forum
I saw dr. Cornel West almost blow the
podium into that audience so he was so
animated I knew that it was something I
wanted to be a part of from that very
moment so in during 2011 when I started
my doctorate I joined up with the forum
back then we were talking about Occupy
Wall Street 2016 we are talking about a
Democratic Socialist gaining millions of
votes throughout the country times are
definitely changing one thing that's
definitely changed and maybe not for the
better is that prices in New York City
continue to ravage the working and
middle classes and unfortunately the
left form as well so back in 2011 when I
was an intern we were completely unpaid
when people asked me what my
compensation was I said an infinite
supply of pretzels Twizzlers and marks
as good vibes that unfortunately is
still the condition that we are in today
so all of you have been given some
different envelopes on your seats and
that is us asking you to open your
hearts your minds and of course your
wallets to contribute to the forum now
we know that fundraising is very
difficult you need to be innovative you
need to be creative I unfortunately for
you all and neither of those things
so I'm going to blatantly rip off a very
successful grassroots campaign
fundraising scheme in the nation right
now it goes like this
the left forum does not accept
contributions from millionaires and
billionaires we have no super PAC we are
relying upon millions and when I say
millions I mean dozens of campaign
contributions from folks just like you
and in all sincerity those contributions
go to wonderful things I'm going to
share a little bit of left forum gossip
with you I'm a very good source for less
left forum gossip because of the growing
influence of the forum we have been
approached from activists and leaders
from across the nation asking us if they
can do forms in their City so we are now
sincerely talking about extending the
left forum outside of just New York in
addition to the conference we have here
two other East Coast cities in fact
there's even the conversation of
bringing left forum all the way to
California's golden coast so we consider
these things great successes but of
course we can only do them depending on
the contributions from all of you folks
but enough about money it's just too
capitalist for me so I want to kick this
off with a little bit of fun and that is
going to start with slam poet Matt
Cedillo he is a revolutionary poet from
Los Angeles California mm-hmm he has
been featured in the LA Times he was and
and kpf our radio plays Matt Sudhir
[Applause]
so a rage rebellion revolution right
that's the theme here we go
rocks in sundown Levittown Fort Apache
Dirty Harry John Wayne blackface
Minuteman Moynihan Gone with the Wind
Breaking Bad Washington [ __ ]
Confederate flag the sword the dollar
the cannon the scholar of the cavalry in
the Ivy League history is written by
lightning is the rising smoke of burning
village the ways and means Victor's keep
their victims of frontier thesis notes
on the state of Virginia extraction
expansion in the Whitney of the West
Lewis and Clark Smith & Wesson has
circled a wagon with bloodshed and
slaves so at the crack of the whip the
law 3/5 the crown republic of king
cotton intended failures of
reconstruction the housing covenants
that create great migrations that same
as the mexicans of poor mexico so far
from heaven and so close the Monroe
Doctrine to Davy Crockett to prison
industrial complex a war on drugs is a
war a young bloody Christmas reefer
madness 15 to life 4 ounces east oakland
west baltimore southla braid oliver
north plymouth/kingston in the Rio
Grande stolen lives stolen land here is
a nation packaged complete police escort
skinheads and hooded Klansmen too much
hate down public streets well it's very
same police quotas to me cannon fire on
black boys and hoodies and Mexican kids
with shaped heads they are killing our
kids well half the nation applauds in
the homelands defense because they think
they think that a white woman's purse
has more value than a black or brown
boy's life here's a nation hell been 1%
genocide pipeline from underfunded
schools to overcrowded prisons in Turkey
which our kids ain't fit for nothing but
a life in and out of the system stripped
of innocence guilts
by birth certificate students quotas
before children children suspects before
students young girls [ __ ]
before victims here is a nation that
eats its young it's not a democracy this
is not a republic this is an open-air
prison industrial scale plantation
anything and everything you've ever
gotten from this system as a
mathematical assessment a calculated
equation set to the algorithm the cost
of doing business
keep your hands moving stomach consuming
mind functioning with narrow confines
your job description blood soaked
country Forge and genocide built on
slavery by den of thieves
posing as messiah the Constitution
Thomas Jefferson Justin Davis why Jesus
Western civilization civilizing mission
mission accomplished manifest destiny
American exceptionalism peculiar
institution socialized race integration
to fight Asian anthem the slave ship the
Bicentennial you're back to the slave
with the feet away liberty dirt poor
dead tired whole child lives in poverty
rates of Ellis Islands Arizona's blood
red high only trails a traffic in brown
flesh brick by brick grave my grave inch
by inch
slave by slave here is a nation there or
its chains keep you in place watchtower
overseer engine killer Union bus because
he is impatient act at again X 12
national defense which of you would
stand against its witch-hunt from us a
blown who shags
who did that which side are you on here
is the firing squad
the guild medic comments because it
comes up the camera will jump Brown the
guilt that Turner they kill the
Rosenbergs they come Soglin there's any
malformation mortgaging you from cells
are the girlfriend Hampton they kill in
much the same fashion here or the
blood-soaked fields in the life of any
Lopez in Flores de Pena Mike Brown's
Orleans Trayvon Martin half the nation
applauded here is that nation is not
what democracy is not a republic this is
the State of the Union they are killing
our children
boy a war this
that's the deal everyone that's the deal
thank you Matt now of course the left
forum would not be able to be here today
if it wasn't for the good folks lobbying
on our behalf at John Shea so everyone
we're gonna bring up a Gerald Markowitz
he is a distinguished professor of
history at John Jay College of Criminal
Justice he received his doctorate in
from the Department of History from the
University of Wisconsin has been
teaching at John Jay since 1970 he has
written extensively about the ways
corporations have undermined the
environment and the health of both
workers and our communities Gerald
Markowitz everyone well it is a great
pleasure for me to welcome you on behalf
the students the faculty the staff and
even the administration of John Jay
College of Criminal Justice and of
course you know we are part of the great
City University of New York and yes who
is here from the City University alumni
students faculty yes way to go way to go
and you know and all of you know that we
are in the midst of a war against public
higher education this is a war that we
are engaged in we are fighting back
against and we are winning some of the
battles but the war goes on and we have
to really emphasize that when the state
does not fund public higher education
this is not a economic decision this is
a political decision that is reflecting
on our students and they are making this
political decision because our students
are predominantly students of color
students of the working class students
who are immigrants or children of
immigrants and we are in the midst of a
tremendous fight back against that part
of that fight back
has been successful the students and the
professional staff Congress our union
was successful in stopping any tuition
increase this year by the state
legislature a great victory but the
faculty and staff have been working
without a contract for six years now
working without a raise for six years
and this just this past week the Union
had a vote of its membership but whether
we should authorize a strike to be
called by the union leadership and I am
proud to announce that 92% of those who
voted voted for a strike authorization
[Applause]
but we need your help we need your
solidarity we need you to join us in
this defense of higher public higher
education thank you very much thank you
so much professor Markowitz last but not
least your host for the evening a woman
who needs practically no introduction
his Laura Flanders is the executive
producer and host of the Laura Flanders
show she was the founder and host of
Grit TV with Laura Flanders her books
include Bush women tales of a cynical
species and blue grid true Democrats
take back politics from the politicians
and she's also available on podcasts
please give her a warm welcome to miss
Laura Flanders thank you and
participants of left forum 2016 that's
you
[Applause]
we're here to take on one particular
part of the conversation at the left
forum this weekend capitalism and
militarism at humanity's peril now I
would say when we have a former Nobel
Peace Prize winner Barack Obama awarding
a distinguished public service award to
Henry Kissinger our humanity is more
than at peril and it tells you a thing
or two about the Nobel Prize but there
is other news to discuss as well we have
the first Muslim mayor elected in London
we have 2.4 million people
contributing to the Bernie Sanders
campaign a man who has not forsworn the
use of drones we have Donald Trump
proving that in case anyone wondered
white supremacy white male patriarchal
supremacy is alive and well and deadly
and we have an election on our hands
while we try to build a movement that
will move beyond this electoral morass I
don't need to tell you that capitalism
today is characterized by massive and
increasing inequality in case you forgot
Oxfam earlier this year reported that 62
people owned the same wealth as half of
the world that's 3.6 billion with a B
people and only nine of those 62 are
women wealth and power accumulates at
one pole while misery austerity and
ecological degradation cluster and
explode at the other having exploited
native land and enslaved people now it
seems to be war and Empire that are
keeping capitalism on life support
thank you for the poem entry McGinnis
we see it in the u.s. and the rise of
racism and fear and the way local police
forces are armed with surplus military
weapons in the use of public funds to
procure mercenary
corporate security forces and enlist
working-class people to fight each other
goaded on here and internationally by
divide-and-conquer surveillance
techniques and inflammatory rhetoric of
white supremacy on my program the Laura
Flanders show which you can see on Telus
or English or Telus or or just tune in
to our podcast at Laura Flanders calm
people regularly reflect about where
we've come to
most recently the Jeremy Scahill no
stranger to all of you considering the
legacy of plowshares peace activists
Phil and Dan Berrigan recalled that our
movements have become increasingly
separated racial justice from economic
justice war and peace from wages of
migration dreams from the time skate
Hill recalled when Black Power activist
Stokely Carmichael called Phil Berrigan
the most dangerous white man alive we've
come a long way how are we now to
understand the connections and I think
that's the the challenge of this
evenings plenary is trying to understand
the connections between for example
extreme policing and mass incarceration
and extreme pilfering and profiteering
and resource extraction most importantly
we're going to talk about where the
cracks are in this system what piece
movements what piece of justice
movements are developing and how they
are tackling Empire what kinds of
leverage both in and beyond the military
industrial complex to workers and others
actually have to disrupt the onslaught
of militarization and where is this
leverage being used to build
alternatives on my show every week we
look not just at what's going wrong but
what is going right we call it the show
the place where the people who say it
can't be done take a backseat to the
people who are doing it so I I can tell
you that we're gonna hear from three
people who we have pretty often on the
program and I know
that they are not just perfect when it
comes to talking about the onslaught
that we're up against but also when it
comes to talking about the opportunities
and how and where people are grabbing
them we're gonna get substantive meaty
presentations by each of our speakers
and then have a little conversation
amongst ourselves and then release us
all to engage one another in one-on-one
conversation or cluster in groups if you
prefer our first speaker today is going
to be Chris Hedges he's a Pulitzer Prize
winning journalist to North amost
recently of wages of rebellion the moral
imperative of revolt
he was a National Book Critics Circle
finalist for his book war is a force
that gives us meaning he's taught at
Columbia NYU Princeton the University of
Toronto he's teaching courses through
Rutgers University to prisoners at a
Correctional Facility in New Jersey and
he is about to launch a new television
show on Russia today Chris Hedges wait
I'm gonna introduce everybody I just
wanted them to applaud you Medea
Benjamin is the co-founder of the
women-led peace group code pink and the
co-founder of the human rights
organization global exchange she's the
author of eight books including drone
warfare killing by remote control and
her articles appear regularly in outlets
such as The Huffington Post common
dreams alternate the other worlds and
tell us or her forthcoming book is on
Saudi Arabia Medea Benjamin
[Applause]
and finally tariq Ali my colleague Telus
or where he hosts a weekly program you
can find out more at Telus or English TV
he was born and raised in Lahore he came
of age in London as an opponent of the
Vietnam War
today he is editorial director of the
London publishing house verso and on the
board of the new left review where he's
also an editor he's the author of too
many books to mention fiction nonfiction
and essays the most recent of those lost
is the extreme centre a warning let's
start with Chris Chris Hedges
thank you very much so when I came in I
was handed a broad sheet that pulled a
quote a half of a quote that I made and
so since I want to talk about the nature
of power during this electoral campaign
I will finish the quote I did indeed say
it is not our job to take power but it
didn't end there it is our job to make
the powerful frightened of us that is
what movements do movements keep power
in check and as any good anarchists will
tell you power is always the problem
no matter who holds it this is some
realization that Karl Popper made in the
open society and its enemies
where he wrote that it is not the job to
get good people to rule that popper says
is the wrong question how do we get good
people to rule rather it is to create a
system where those in power are
frightened of us yes we certainly want
to push forward into power those who
will listen but without those movements
without the power of movements to keep
the powerful in check all power becomes
despotic and this was an understanding
that julia benda had in his great book
the treason of the intellectuals where
he said that all of us who care to
create a society based on justice a
society that takes care of the
vulnerable and the weak among us that
expresses compassion are given a choice
between choosing two sets of ideals
privilege and power or justice and truth
but has been to rights the more we make
concessions to those who serve privilege
and power the more we diminish the
capacity for justice and truth we just
finished a session
on Rosa Luxemburg who I think of all
revolutionary theorists probably
understood this the best it is important
that we rebuild these movements now
movements that have been destroyed
consciously in the name of
anti-communism especially at this crisis
moment within the American political and
economic system where we are teetering
on the brink of a very frightening form
of proto fascism one of the mistakes
that Bernie Sanders made a mistake that
Shama saw want and I called him out on
before he announced his campaign was the
decision to run within the embrace of
the Democratic Party and we are now
watching Bernie Sanders supporters and I
think arguably Sanders himself confront
the fact that this has been a rigged
system that when you have a system let's
not forget by the way that the cost of
running the primaries is paid for by the
taxpayer and yet the primary rules are
determined by the Democratic Party so
that they can manipulate a system as
they did in Nevada to steal the vote
from Sanders they lock out independence
this is why in that last cycle Sanders
only one Rhode Island that was the only
state in which independents were allowed
to vote you have a system of
super-delegates
you have money from super PACs it's very
clear that without all of these
mechanisms Sanders would win the
nomination and yet through this long
process we have been given palpable
evidence that democracy within the
United States is a facade and we are
about to enter an electoral process with
two presidential candidates
who have the highest negativity ratings
in American history Donald Trump being
number one and Hillary Clinton being
number two and those of us who care
about recovering agency within our
country overthrowing the corporate coup
d'etat that has taken place and just for
homeland security who might be here
tonight let me repeat that word that's
called overthrow we are going to have to
step outside that system and build
movements that resist we are going to
have to free ourselves from the
insidious mantra of the least worst
because it doesn't work every election
cycle were fed the mantra of the least
worst and it gets worse because our
two-party duopoly why it has a different
rhetoric serves the same centers of
power and that is why on all of the
major structural issues there has been
complete continuity between george w
bush and barack obama with the caveat
that Barack Obama's assault on civil
liberties has been worse and I speak as
a plaintiff in a lawsuit that I brought
against the president over section 1021
of the National Defense Authorization
Act this is a provision that overturns
the 1878 Posse Comitatus Act that
prohibits the military from carry out
carrying out domestic policing and much
to the chagrin of the Obama
administration we won in the Southern
District Court of New York and judge
Katherine DeForest in a very lucid
opinion explaining her ruling 112 pages
said that what this Act does is empower
the government to criminalize an entire
category of people and detain them
without due process
and she brought up the play of the
hundred and ten thousand
japanese-americans who were detained in
World War two
because this section authorizes the US
military on the streets of our cities to
carry out extraordinary renditions
against US citizens deny them due
process if the state deems them to be a
terrorist and holds them indefinitely in
our black sites including our offshore
penal colonies and the two-year legal
process the Obama administration
immediately appealed now they
immediately appeal the day of the ruling
they went in to judge forces chambers
and they demanded that she lifts her
temporary injunction in the name of
national security and when the federal
attorneys came in they now came in with
attorneys from the NSA and judge Forrest
to her credit refused that was on a
Friday afternoon at 9:00 a.m. they were
in the second circuit or the appellate
court of New York demanding the same
thing and unfortunately the Second
Circuit agreed why lawyers Bruce Efron
and Carl Mayer and I wondered why why we
knew they'd appeal but why were they so
aggressive and the only thing that we
could surmise is because it's already
they are already using the law there are
already dual nationals Pakistani US
Nationals being held in black sites and
if they could get out and if they could
get legal representation the government
would be held in contempt of court and
what was the response the Second Circuit
it's a panel of judges they review the
case
they wouldn't rule they wouldn't rule
they wouldn't rule for months and during
that time the lawyers went to Nancy
Pelosi and they said because this
provision is renewed every year all you
have to do is insert into the provision
that US citizens are exempt and of
course they did not because it was
written for US citizens and so what does
the Second Circuit do it doesn't want to
rule on the merits of the case because
it's patently unconstitutional in the
way that our vissa
nation of privacy is unconstitutional
and it essentially was another example
of how the courts have become wholly
owned subsidiaries of the corporate
state and revoked constitutional rights
by judicial Fiat what they did was wait
for a Supreme Court ruling called
clapper versus Amnesty International and
that was a plaintiff in that ruling this
was challenging the government's
wholesale surveillance before the
Snowden revelations and the federal
attorneys got up the government
attorneys got up in the Supreme Court
and said that I and the other plaintiffs
did not have a right to bring the case
because the idea that the government was
watching us was speculation and they
added if the government was watching us
they would tell us so the Supreme Court
buying this argument threw it out and
then the Second Circuit said well hedges
doesn't have standing in clapper versus
Amnesty International therefore he
doesn't have standing in hedges versus
Obama our cert our petition of the
supreme court was turned down in its law
this is all under Obama it's Obama
that's used the Espionage Act to destroy
whistleblowers who once sought out
independent journalists to expose
corruption malfeasance and crimes
against government and here we must
honor two of our greatest whistleblowers
Chelsea Manning and Julian Assange
[Applause]
and Edward Snowden and if you don't have
a third party option then I would
encourage you to just write in Chelsea
Manning or Edward Snowden let me talk a
little bit about what's coming
I think Sanders made a disastrous
mistake I understand his logic when
shamah and I asked him or you know
encouraged him to run as an independent
he answered I don't want to end up like
Ralph Nader and what he really said is I
don't want to take on the democratic
party establishment and become a
political pariah
because Sanders has played I think a
very or built a very Faustian bargain
with the Democratic Party he campaigned
for Bill Clinton in 92 he campaigned for
Clinton in 96 after NAFTA after the
destruction of our welfare system and
remember under original welfare
guidelines 70% of the recipients were
children after the 1994 omnibus crime
bill that exploded the system of mass
incarceration that I want to address a
little bit at the end the deregulation
of the FCC that turned the airwaves over
to AB roughly a half dozen corporations
all this was Clinton night in 2004
Sanders was calling on Nader to suspend
his campaign Sanders has always served
as a kind of watchdog for the Democratic
Party and in return they have not
mounted a serious campaign to unseat him
in Vermont and he in turn has done
everything he can to stymie third party
movements in Vermont
I think Sanders honestly believed that
he had a chance I think we are watching
now a legitimate anger on the part of
Sanders and those around him as they
understand that the game was fixed from
the beginning and yet I fear that
Sanders will do what he says he's going
to do which has endorsed the Democratic
domine and at that moment Sanders
becomes an impediment to social change
if Bernie Sanders does not want to build
a third party movement then we are going
to have to build it without it and we
are going to have to free ourselves from
this belief that we are going to make
serious social change within the
confines of a particular electoral cycle
we are going to have to begin to
organize and recognize that what we are
building towards may be 10 years away
when serezha began it was polling 4% by
the time serezha took power it had a
majority within Greece we have to hold
fast to that moral imperative we have to
stand up and be willing to defy the
system we have to step outside of the
system and the system will be ruthless
in terms of its response but we are
reaching a moment a convergence of
deadly environmental degradation
breakdown we're already watching it many
of the refugees and migrants that are
streaming into Europe yes there's war
but there's also tremendous drought in
Syria
and this system is incapable of
responding in a rational way to the
degradation of the environment caused by
the fossil fuel industry and let me not
forget the animal agriculture industry
Wall Street has been unleashed once
again with money that has been given by
the Fed at roughly zero percent interest
and so at some point we are going to see
another financial crisis that may be
twinned with an ecological crisis and at
that point of breakdown within a system
that is incapable of responding except
to further enrich and empower a global
corporate elite you will have large
segments of the population we are also
we are witnessing this at the moment in
Europe turning to these proto-fascist
forces that are embodied in figures like
Trump Richard Rorty
in his book achieving our country was
the last book he wrote warned that the
inability of self-identified liberal
elites to respond to the suffering of
the underclass while it continued to
speak in the language of diversity and
multiculturalism was actually empowering
the nativist racist homophobic forces
that are gathering around Trump why
because they redefined empowerment what
in feminism become not empowering
oppressed women the way Andrea Dworkin
called us to do but by having a woman
president or a woman CEO and that lie
which was perpetuated by liberal elites
because the assault on people of color
has been far more draconian that it has
been on the white working-class allows
demagogues like Trump to sell a message
to dispossessed whites that they have
been disadvantaged or disenfranchised
because entitlements have been given to
other marginalized groups and the the
lie of our liberal elite has essentially
come back a kind of blowback against
them if Hillary Clinton becomes
president a figure a political figure
who embodies everything on each sides of
the political spectrum we have come to
detest it
then you may get rid of trouble but you
will vomit up somebody even more vile
and the only way that we're going to be
able to break the back of this rising
proto-fascist movement tied to the gun
culture and the Christian Right is to
build a viable left that holds fast to
the moral imperative of defending the
interests of working men and women in
this country and is willing to be pushed
outside of power for a certain period of
time rather than dilute or give up that
moral imperative which is something by
the way that Rosa Luxemburg understood
and it's we who have to do it and if we
don't do it then we are going to see
ourselves slide into a very frightening
form of despotism one where a state or a
system of neoliberalism which has lost
all credibility is forced to maintain
power by carrying out increasingly more
vicious and brutal forms of violence
this is something Hannah Arendt
understood in origins of totalitarianism
when she wrote about the stateless which
is essentially what people of color in
marginal communities are stateless they
have no rights they have been taken from
them police serve as judge jury and
executioner and I teach as you heard in
a prison I just finished teaching
Sheldon Wolens great work politics and
vision to my class
94% of the people in our prison system
never had a trial because the system is
designed to deny them a trial in fact
the students I teach who have the
longest sentences went to trial and they
were punished for it because they
stacked charges against you and then
they barter like a poker game but if you
go to court all of those charges are
arrayed against you and they have to
give you a longer sentence because they
use you as an example they say look he
went to trial or she went to trial and
that's the sentence they got so you
better take the sentence we're offering
you can understand the awful dynamics of
the corporate state by looking at what
it does to the most vulnerable among us
and the best place to do that is in a
prison where corporations have reached
their deadly tentacles down to every
facet of prison life Global tel link
which has taken over the phone services
and let's remember the phone is the
primary way that children remain in
contact with their incarcerated parents
it's four to five times higher than what
we pay commissary has been privatized
and prices have ratcheted upwards in New
Jersey you make $28 a month for 40 hours
a week
it's neo slavery it's alive and well and
prices are now beyond reach you are no
longer given shoes in the state of New
Jersey you have to spend forty five
dollars for a pair of Reeboks if you
send a money transfer through je pay
it's privatized so you send twenty
dollars you get a four ninety five
service fee on and on and on fees are
now imposed on you in prison for
instance if you have a bereavement visit
to someone who's dying or you visit a
member of the immediate family who's
dead in 15 minutes you get you pay for
the guards the overtime it's $900 so my
students are getting out of prison
thousands of
in debt and when they get out of prison
and thousands of dollars in debt as ex
felons they can't get jobs one because
there aren't any jobs and two because
they're demonized and if they can't
maintain those payments they go right
back into prison and that's why that guy
who got stopped for a taillight runs and
is shot in the back some people say the
mat system of mass incarceration doesn't
work no no they're wrong it works just
the way it's designed to work it works
because we have created with a loss of
our manufacturing base and the assault
on our working class a group of surplus
labor who do not they're brown and black
bodies do not generate an income for
corporations until they are locked in
cages where they can generate 40 or 50
thousand dollars a year and the students
I teach understand that reform is not
going to be come from state legislatures
or from Congress because corrections
corporal tell they've all got their
lobbyists they're writing the
legislation go on Corrections corporate
America the largest for-profit prison
complex in the in the country and on the
website it says we are a good investment
because there are 67 percent recidivism
rate in the United States which is why
there are no programs vocational
educational any other programs and they
understand as they have done and I will
close with this
that the only mechanism left is to carry
out nationwide work stoppages within
those prisons because no prison can
operate unless you have prison labor and
that is an example for all of us
they just carried one out in Alabama in
Georgia on the anniversary of Attica on
September 9th they're organizing a
nationwide prison stoppage and as they
have said over and over
don't go demonstrate in front of a
courthouse when we carry out that work
stop it come to the parking lot of the
prisons and stand with us let us all
follow their example let us understand
that we if we mobilize and stand up and
begin to disrupt this system we can take
power back into our own hands and
eventually build in the years ahead
towards the destruction of the corporate
state thank you
[Applause]
so I love Chris but I don't know that I
agree with you about Bernie Sanders not
that he should have run separate because
I think he's done an amazing thing
within the Democratic Party which is get
a lot of young people engaged and
educate millions and millions of
Americans about the economic the
tremendous economic disparity in this
country talk about issues of mass
incarceration to people who haven't
heard that before
incorporate the issues that black lives
matter is brought to him and also show
their tremendous split in the Democratic
Party and if Bernie hadn't run you
wouldn't see that there is on one side a
Democratic Party that's represented by
Hillary Clinton and wall street in the
weapons industries and all that's wrong
in this country and the other side are
people who really want to see the
Democratic Party represent their values
and those are values that Bernie sander
is standing for so
raise your hand if you worked on or
voted for Bernie raise your hand if you
plan to vote for Hillary Clinton now you
might see that's just a very small
sprinkling here raise your hand if you
plan to vote for Jill Stein Wow raise
your hand if you plan to vote for Garry
Johnson the libertarian huh
raise your hand if you plan to vote for
Donald Trump
we got one gentleman over there one over
there so it's fascinating times in this
country it's a fascinating time to be
with a group like this and it's a
fascinating time to think about the
opportunities that we have now and that
we're going to have next January first I
want to just summarize what has happened
to the peace movement under Obama now
let's remember that Obama came to power
because he beat Hillary Clinton and he
beat Hillary Clinton why the Iraq war
the Iraq war he was perceived as a peace
candidate and that's how he became
president now let's give him a credit
for a couple of good things really good
things that have happened in these last
seven plus years
one is the Iran nuclear deal incredibly
important done against great odds with
the help of a lot of people in this room
I'm sure but going up against big lobby
groups like AIPAC going up against
Israel going up against a lot of powers
that did not want to see this go through
and it one and the other is Cuba let's
recognize that Obama did an amazing job
opening up to Cuba there's still a lot
to be done the embargo still exists
but let's recognize these are two
diplomatic successes that happened under
his administration but also let's not
forget they did not happen while Hillary
Clinton was Secretary of State they
happened after Hillary Clinton left and
John Kerry came in and acted more like a
diplomat so those are two positive
things that have happened but there have
been so many bad things that have
happened on the part foreign policy
front front let's remember that this
piece President as Laura Flanders said
who got the Nobel Peace Prize did not
get us out of the wars of Iraq or
Afghanistan has bombed seven countries
at least Iraq Afghanistan Pakistan Yemen
Somalia Libya and Syria has not closed
Guantanamo as he promised in fact
instead of closing Guantanamo he would
have been embarrassed to put more
prisoners into Guantanamo and his answer
was instead to use drones to just kill
people instead of capturing them and
imprisoning them and so he became the
drone commander-in-chief that has spread
this horrendous technology not only
being used in the United States but is
spreading it to many other countries
around the world
he didn't close the over 800 military
bases we have overseas in fact has been
involved in building new bases and in
case anybody hasn't noticed all of this
militarism has not led to a decrease in
terrorist groups has only led to a
spread and a change of name from things
like al-qaeda to the Islamic state Trump
on the other hand is saying we got to
rebuild the military if I get elected as
if the new military needs something like
more money six hundred and thirty two
billion dollars the budget this year
obscene amount of money but that even
hides other monies that are not good
sidered with the Pentagon budget that if
you put them together like Veterans
Affairs money from the Energy Department
that go to nuclear weapons you I add all
of that together it's about a trillion
dollars not only is it fifty four
percent of all of our discretionary
money but it's more money than the rest
of the world combined we have the most
grotesque military in terms of our
taxpayer dollars and guess what they
can't win a war and that's not because
they're underfunded it's because they're
sent to fight in unwinnable Wars that we
have to get out of
[Applause]
let's not just blame it on Barack Obama
let's look at Congress I live in
Washington DC now and unfortunately I
get to see it up close and raw when you
go into these congressional hearings and
you see these Congress people from the
Democrats and the Republican side
falling over each other to give more
money to the Pentagon than the Pentagon
even asked for and when the Pentagon
wants to close a base here and there
Congress says oh no you couldn't close
that base it's in my district it will
mean jobs and when the Pentagon says oh
we don't need those c-17 planes anymore
they're old they're not useful the cargo
planes the Pennock the congress says oh
no we couldn't possibly kill that
program it would mean 35,000 jobs and it
would be in my district and of course
the weapons manufacturers know this game
all too well it is their game after all
and they make the parts of their weapons
in as many congressional districts as
possible take the most expensive weapon
weapon in the history of the world the
f-35 made in pieces of it in every
single congressional district and the
weapons manufacturers then give money to
the Congress people in those districts
so the Congress keep people keep pushing
those weapons and the Congress people
turn around and they don't say of course
oh we have to keep these weapons going
so I can get money from my campaign
instead they say jobs jobs jobs now what
an insane way to have a jobs program
after all the military is probably the
only job creation program we have in the
United States millions of people are
employed and active duty and reserve
millions and millions more for feeding
the military machine and it is you know
freed zakaria who's i don't think you
would call a socialist he's a pretty
mainstream
economists on CNN writes in The
Washington Post he calls the US military
the largest socialist economy in the
world he says its cradle to grave
socialism you get your money you get
your early retirement you get your
pension you get health care for your
entire life and your family you get free
housing you get take care you get early
retirement
you get goodies from movie theaters to
golf course it is indeed a jobs program
the former Secretary of State Robert
Gates said I don't know if he was
boasting but he said there are more
members in the military marching bands
than they are in the entire state
department Foreign Service an insane
jobs program making things that make us
unsafe nothing we need to live they
don't make food they don't make things
for us to wear to house ourselves they
don't provide infrastructure for us
nothing that we as consumers need it's
not even a good job creation program if
you look at the studies that are done
that showed when you put a billion
dollars into providing jobs in the
military you get about 11,000 jobs if
you put it into education you'd get
29,000 jobs if you put it into anything
else you would get more jobs in fact I
don't think they counted this one but I
would be pretty sure if you took all
that money and dropped it from airplanes
on to people that they would create a
lot more jobs than the military would
create
and it doesn't keep us safe as I
mentioned there are more groups that
would like to attack us than there were
before Isis is indeed a threat we just
see probably a terrorist attack on the
plane that came down going from France
to Egypt but let's remember what Martin
Luther King said at the time of the
Vietnam War stands - today the u.s. is
the largest purveyor of violence in the
world and it's not only the violence
that the u.s. does directly it's also
the indirect violence because our number
one industrial export right now is what
weapons and when you're number one
export is weapons you're number one
global marketing strategy is endless war
so the u.s. sells weapons lots and lots
of weapons and the number one purchaser
of US weapons is no it's not Israel
Saudi Arabia that's right now think of
how absurd and how obscene this is Saudi
Arabia a country that is number one and
beheadings in the world a country that
treats women as minors their entire
lives the only country in the world
where women are not even allowed to
drive a country that exports extremism
waha BISM the distorted form of Islam
that is exported around the world thanks
to the petrol dollars that the Saudis
have the Saudis who got involved in the
internal affairs of Yemen dropping bombs
since March of last year that have
killed thousands of people thousands of
innocent people could have taken taken
that poor country of yay
to the extreme of a humanitarian crisis
with our weapons including cluster bombs
banned by the international community
that makes us complicit in war crimes
the Saudis are number one purchaser of
weapons the number one recipient of US
military money is Israel another major
human rights violator an apartheid state
that on a daily basis is oppressing the
Palestinian people that state is the
number one recipient of our tax dollars
to the tune of three billion dollars a
year but that's not enough for the
Israeli government in fact to give their
ok to the Iran nuclear deal they said
you must sweeten this by giving billions
more to us they wanted five billion
Obama said let's go for 4 billion we're
at four billion negotiations still going
on they want more this is where our tax
dollars go this is where our weapons go
number two recipient military aid Egypt
an extreme violator of human rights that
came to power through a coup and it's
not enough to sell those weapons
overseas those weapons manufacturers
those greedy weapons manufacturers that
Pope Francis said have blood on their
hands are also looking for more internal
markets they look at the 18,000 police
departments in the United States and
they want to sell their weapons and
their tanks their assault rifles their
grenade launchers their drones they want
to sell them right here in our
communities to put down our own people
particularly poor people of color who
are the victims of the militarization of
our police forces
so here we have a war economy out of
control
a weapons a military-industrial complex
out of control and a peace movement that
has been incapable of striking fear into
those in power and moving them away from
this military-industrial complex so
let's recognize that another place we
have to put blame for all of this is
ourselves for not being capable of
building the kind of movement that we
need the effective movement to put
pressure in the places where we need to
put it so now we look at the
opportunities that we have
well when Obama came in our peace
movement died we had a strong peace
movement under Bush Obama came in people
said oh that peace president is going to
take care of it he obviously didn't well
fool me once what a George Bush say
don't fool me again I think one positive
weakens thing we can say about a
prospect of either a Hillary Clinton or
a Donald Trump presidency is we will be
not fooled again there are no illusions
that either Donald Trump or Hillary
Clinton are going to be the peace
presidents that we need
there is no illusion that they are going
to get us out of the endless wars it's
interesting that Donald Trump has said
of a couple of interesting things hasn't
he like that NATO is obsolete it's a
great thing to say it certainly is
obsolete he even said that he would talk
to Kim jong-un of North Korea it's a
positive thing to say but let's not be
fooled by Donald Trump and remember at
the heart of his campaign is the
Islamophobia that he's been preaching is
the anti-immigrant hatred that he has
been preaching he's even said that he
would bring back torture do whatever you
have to
so Donald Trump is certainly not going
to be a peace president but he that
gives us the opening because people will
be ready to protest in fact just
yesterday in DC we protested at the
opening of Hillary Clinton's offices and
it was quite amusing because we went as
billionaires for Hillary we went as with
signs that says I make weapons I love
Hillary Wall Street loves Hillary and we
stood outside as the mayor of Washington
DC went in as different officials went
in and they looked at us in kind of her
as we said we are the 1% we want Hillary
for president and Hillary Hillary she's
our gal take our corporate money now but
the workers were working for those
officials came out and said to us thank
you for being here we agree with you
100% there are lots of people that agree
with us and that are happy to see us
protesting already from the get-go about
Hillary taking money from Wall Street
about Hillary representing the weapons
industry about Hillary taking ten
million dollars from the Saudis as part
of her Clinton Foundation these are
things that have to be exposed whether
or not Hillary Clinton makes it to the
White House
we need these movements to pressure her
and the other thing we need to do is
build an alternative to the war economy
that does not depend on who is in the
White House and let me just say on
building this alternative economy it's a
couple of things and one is happening
already on a very wide scale which is
called the localized economy I'm sure
that many of you are part of it instead
of investing in the big
banks you invest in credit unions
instead of buying from factory farms you
buy from local farmers and organic farms
instead of buying from sweatshops you
buy from thrift stores instead of the
crafts consumption you reuse and you
recycle instead of buying fracked oil
you buy your energy from solar and wind
this is the kind of economy we have to
build and from the war economy we have
to convert from the top down remember
converge and it was a big thing during
the 70s and 80s we have to bring back
the whole idea of economic conversion
where we take these militaries and bases
and the factories and turn them into the
wind farms we need turn them into the
solar farms we need instead of aegis
destroyers that are floating in the Gulf
we should turn them into floating
hospitals that are going to take care of
the refugees and the people who are
fleeing from the wars that we start and
the people who are fleeing from the
National natural disasters from the
climate crisis this is what we need to
turn the war economy into and so I want
to end by saying that we have a
tremendous opportunity to show that
whether it's Donald Trump or Hillary
Clinton they represent an economy that's
built on competition we want one that's
built on cooperation instead of one
that's built on constant growth that
destroys the future we want one built on
sitting a sustainability instead of one
built on us versus them we want one
that's built on interconnectiveness
instead of one that judges success by
wealth like Donald Trump from casinos to
luxury hotels
- how many golf courses he's built we
want ones that are measured by healthy
communities and healthy ecosystems we
want a vision that engages and inspires
and unites people from the black lives
matter movement the immigrant rights
movement the peace movement the
environmental movement the labor rights
the artists the students to say that we
will only give
peace a chance when we challenge those
in power and replace the war economy
with a local peace economy thank you
[Applause]
friends very happy to be here some of us
have been watching Mike is not all can
you hear me now I said very glad to be
here especially at this time because
though we are talking about the
presidential candidates senator Clinton
and Donald Trump war has really been
exciting watching what is going on from
afar in the United States has been these
huge mobilizations of young people in
favor of a candidate who talks of
socialism we can now and what I want to
tell you is that this movement of young
people which has brought many more
people together than one could have
imagined much larger than any political
campaign
I remember involving trying to go for it
against the mainstream then at any other
time in recent American history the
Vietnam anti-vietnam war movement didn't
create a political side to it even
though Martin Luther King was talking of
running as an alternative president not
inside the Democratic Party but together
with dr. spoke challenging the
Democratic Party that didn't happen one
reason it didn't happen as he was killed
so what we are witnessing is a very
interesting radicalization and it's a
radicalization of young people which is
how is happening in most countries in
Europe today why since the 2008 Wall
Street Crash
many people felt especially those who
had absolutely no idea or no alternative
view that somehow the governors of the
world the rulers of this world
capitalist world would manage to put
something new in place that would give
some comfort to the poor and to the
young who suffer even more on many
levels lack of housing too much to pay
for education and increasingly in some
parts of Europe health as well so we
have national health services they are
under very heavy fire and attack from
American Health corporations who are
increasingly being given contracts by
state-owned health services as part of
the neoliberal system so in this
situation it was felt that if the elites
who ruled the world were a bit more
rational they would attempt to put in
place something different something that
had been tried before it didn't happen
and after a short wait you had the
emergence of new popular movements from
the left and you had the emergence of
mass movements from the right this
process began in different ways in
different countries but we can now see a
pattern as we can see in the United
States - and this pattern is as follows
you have had the only country where you
don't have a far-right movement is Spain
because the Left have been very dominant
in Spanish society in Spanish political
culture but the Conservative Party in
that country the so-called Popular Party
has been moving further and further to
the right itself and all these movements
had
one thing in common they developed from
the grassroots they developed often in
one part of the country either a region
Sicily in the case of the five star
movement Madrid in the case of the
occupation of the squares in Spain and
then spread rapidly from there to the
rest of the country we've been
witnessing now even as I speak the rise
of a new popular movement in France
again a movement which pushes all the
established political parties to one
side and says we don't trust you all the
intellectuals who serve these parties we
don't trust you keep away move away and
we want to unite with trade unions to
fight against the new laws that the
French Socialist government so-called is
bringing and putting onto the statute
book to restrict labor rights in France
and this movement comes together at
night some of them work during the day
others think it's a nice time to do it
to occupy the night la nuit debout the
night rising and they meet an
increasingly this movement which started
in Paris is spreading and has spread to
other parts of France they've been
clashes with the riot police etc etc in
Britain the radicalization took a
different form much to everyone's
surprise something odd happened and what
happened was that in order to reduce the
power of the trade unions in the labor
movement inside the labor party the
labor right was pushing for a a virtual
primary system but different that anyone
who was a labor supporter and paid 3
pounds could join the labour party and
participate in the election for the
leadership of this
that's how it happened they assumed that
like in France this would benefit the
right because people on the right
generally assumed that most people are
like them in Britain dis turned out not
to be the case
once this room came into effect and one
of the candidates was Jeremy Corbyn a
long time socialist a longtime supporter
of the campaign for nuclear disarmament
a longtime campaigner against the wars
in the Middle East a longtime defender
of Palestinian rights who had said for
decades that the Trident nuclear
missiles in Britain should be got rid
off he said all this in his campaigning
for the Labour Party leadership and this
they had to broadcast this on television
unlike here they couldn't pick and
choose because if all the other
candidates were on he had to be on and
lots of young people who hadn't heard
these things before never heard of them
and he said that one of the things he
would do if he was elected a leader of
the Labour Party would be to realise the
railway networks would be to end
privatization of education and would be
to end all fees that students have been
forced to pay for higher education
[Applause]
within weeks 200,000 people had paid
their 3 pounds and joined the Labour
Party I didn't do it out of principle
but many of my friends did and they
voted to the astonishment of the media
which had been denouncing him as a crazy
as a loony as a not who could you know
living in a different world a dinosaur
well he got elected leader of the Labour
Party and that has now created huge
problems within the Labour Party and
between Corbin and the establishment
this is in Britain the so called
motherland of democracy that a senior
military general serving general gave an
interview to The Sunday Times one of
Rupert Murdoch's papers saying that if
Corbin was elected prime minister of
england there would be mutinies in the
army and they would refuse to obey
orders that happened another general
appeared on a 2 breakfast time
television show saying that the decision
not to ditch the Trident nuclear
missiles was unacceptable would weakens
Britain defences and Corbin was not
suitable as a prime minister
so whence a conservative Grande was
asked what the hell is going on can't
you control the army this is unheard of
in Britain he said oh well technically
you know of course the Queen is the
commander-in-chief of the army
so I wrote at the time that's fine then
we all want to live under a banana
monarchy because that's what they are
saying so the campaign against Corbin
has been huge and so far things have
been proceeding not too badly attempts
to force him to retreat on trident have
failed attempts to force him to retreat
on other things have so far failed and
his popularity is slowly growing and
attempts to remove him as leader of the
Labour Party opinion poll after opinion
poll shows if they did that and he stood
again he would get larger majorities as
leader now in Spain a mass popular
movement podemos organized itself as a
loose party a party movement a movement
party not a traditional party and came
within two percentage points of
defeating through traditional right-wing
Socialist Party in that country I say
this very carefully and cautiously
simply to register that there is anger
on the streets and in people's homes and
this is the way they respond this is the
way this generation is responding
korban in britain Sanders here movements
challenging social democracy there what
are their demands effectively if one is
totally frank what these people are
demanding from the rulers and from the
bankers who run this world is a little
bit of social democracy not too much
they are saying we won't ask for too
much but we do want a health system that
is not privatized we do want free
education we want cheap homes and we
want our railways taken back
don't want all the utilities being
privatized in island there was a huge
struggle against water privatization so
in these movements by demanding little
they are attracting huge numbers of
people and the question then comes is
the capitalist state in these countries
prepared to accept a government elected
on the basis of these demands the
indications are not good because what we
are witnessing effectively is a
hollowing out of the democratic process
itself as Chris has been talking about
that they don't care anymore
they don't need to prove that they're
Democrats to anyone gone are the days of
the Cold War when the idea of giving
more space to dissidents in the media
was necessary to show the Communist
world look we are better than you that's
all gone they don't need to prove it and
they feel they can do what they want and
when there's resistance they try their
initial reaction is to try and crush it
ideologically saying you are Putin's
agent so you're working for terrorism or
you're doing this so you're on the grip
of Islam by the way the country in
Europe which is the most Islamophobic
much more so than the US is France
horrific absolutely horrific
Islamophobia is in has infected a large
chunk of their intellectuals when the
kids and the band leaves the the suburbs
struggle very few white organizations
off the left come in support of them you
can name three four four intellectuals
who defend them so Islam me of
Islamophobia is huge eyes and trance
before I came here and whenever I was
interviewed the shock and horror when
they said
once at a public event not on like this
about five or six people said and you
now have a Muslim mayor in London I said
I know France is in a state of shock but
we're in a state of shock because he's a
very right-wing mayor he completely
defends corporate interests he is
completely opposed to what Jeremy Corbyn
stands for and he is cozying up to those
who attacked him
the Conservatives so it's big for you
that we have a Muslim mayor but we judge
him not by his skin colour or his
religion but by his politics and by what
he's going to do that is our definition
[Applause]
because you know this is not a big deal
in in in in in Britain lots of members
of parliament not lots but a fair amount
are Muslims of Muslim origin a
conservative member of the government
cabinet the business secretary no less
is of Muslim origin the former
chairperson of the Conservative Party
who resigned his chairperson Baroness
Warsi is a Muslim and they come like the
new mayor from humble backgrounds you
know their fathers were first-generation
migrants so it's a huge mistake to fall
into the trap of thinking that
automatically identity is the politics
of identity are progressive sometimes
they are obviously in black lives matter
it's a huge movement and a very welcome
movement and a movement which is broken
with all the opportunists black
politicians who hang on the coattails of
democratic or the Democrat politicians
that's the most important thing about
black lives matter but the case of Asian
politicians in Europe is very different
very different
so each each has to be judged according
to their politics and what they do when
they come to power I just want to speak
briefly about which Medea has already
done very eloquently about the state of
the Middle East you know this is a part
of the world that ISM was made into what
it is after the First World War when the
British and French armies went in and
created these small states prior to this
the Middle East was one area the Arab
world and dominated by large cities
under the rule of the Ottomans a very
loose form of rule by the way so that
you could go to school in Amman in
Jordan you could go to a better school
secondary school in Jerusalem and you
could get your university degree in
Cairo or Damascus that's how that world
used to function
then came the First World War and the
division of the Middle East the Arab
East into little States and British
civil servants Imperial civil servants
used to boast when asked how did you
draw the borders of Iraq and go through
Bell the civil servant in question she
said with a stick in the sand that's how
we did did it now we are witnessing a
new Imperial process carried out by this
Empire who citizens you all are of re
dividing the Middle East and even even a
more reactionary fashion the invasion of
Iraq what did it effectively do by
destroying the previous state completely
something they didn't do in Japan after
the second
something they didn't do in Italy after
the Second World War where 60 to 70% of
fascist personnel in the Armed Forces
the police the judiciary were retained
that they didn't even do fully in chin
in Germany in West Germany 20 to 30
percent of the previous personnel
including the Chiefs of the intelligence
services of the Third Reich were
retained by the United States to fight
the new Cold War but Iraq completely
different destroy every single remnant
of the old state hand over power to
Shiite clerical parties and the result
has been a disaster a disaster nearly 2
million people killed during the
occupation of Iraq 5 million orphans
millions of refugees in neighboring
countries and the war in Iraq which we
were told was over now more troops are
being sent in to fight Isis which was
created by the first war in the in the
first place has gone on longer than the
first world war
longer than the second world war the
wars in Afghanistan have gone on longer
than the last Vietnam wars and longer
than the first and second world wars and
you know when a country is occupied
however it's occupied it has a deeply
damaging effect on the psyche of all its
people regardless of which religious
faction they come from and this is now
what is happening very few people think
that Iraq can survive as a state
northern Iraq the Kurdish areas are
already an American Israeli Protectorate
and function as such the Iranians
control Shiite Iraq the Saudis via
through Isis are trying to
another part of Iraq so the old Iraq
that remains United for good or for bad
since the first world war is about to be
divided again Syria virtually the same
thing is going on there because it is in
the interests of the Empire and its
close allies in the region Saudi Arabia
in Israel to divide them into little
tiny statelets which can be controlled
from outside
hence the destruction of the Iraqi army
was considered vital it was the last one
of the last sovereign states
hence the destruction of Syria
regardless of the absurdities or even
crimes of their rulers has to be
destroyed to destroy any states which
have sovereignty that is not permitted
in this day and age Afghanistan is a
complete and utter mess and as some of
us argued when they first went in this
war is going to go into Pakistan
and it has done wrecking the social
fabric of that country and the drone
attacks don't help you know there was a
remarkable situation some years ago when
the Iranian government which was then
considered a top-level enemy government
the policeman fighting against
demonstrators which was of course wrong
accidentally killed a young girl
everyone admits it wasn't deliberate as
happens here all the time it was an
accident
Obama emerged in the White House long
trying to squeeze out a tear the
American press went absolutely crazy and
that very and headlines and that very
same day in Pakistan a drone attack had
killed 56 women and children when they
targeted a school by mistake
not a mention in most Western newspapers
and it is these double standards that
drive people mad and crazy and they want
revenge it's not too difficult to
understand why many young Muslims are
going in this direction to be frank I'm
surprised and there are not more one
should be pleased there or not more
because given the extent of the
provocation this is what they want to do
take revenge saying why why can they get
away with killing us why shouldn't we do
the same and of course one argues
sometimes against this when I'm
confronted with it but you know you
don't know how to fight etc etc they say
that so in such a situation what is what
are we going to do well in the United
States of course those of you who live
here know better than me but again
watching it from afar I think the model
which Madeira has outlined local
strength building local grassroots I
would add to that building political
bases locally and on a statewide level
before expending our energies on a
national campaign that's what the left
is capable of doing the Seattle example
is a very good one when an excellent
campaign by a socialist Sarma Sawant
has resulted in her winning at the
elections again to the council despite
every democratic action against her and
the Democrats trying to find a candidate
of color etc they want it's a good model
and one shouldn't sit back one shouldn't
one shouldn't sit back and do nothing
and wait and that is the encouraging
thing I have to be honest with you when
I read some opinion poll which said that
30% of those who've been supporting
Bernie have said that they will not
under any circumstances vote for Hillary
Clinton
I think that's positive we live in a
very strange world a world of transition
in which the system that is in place is
not working everyone knows it's not
working we know it's not working and
those who run the system know it's not
working because worried working even a
tiny bit then all these jokers in Wall
Street the bankers who stole money half
of them would be in prison for what they
did
that's what happened in a tiny little
place called Iceland you heard of
Iceland they locked up most of the
bankers involved in deals like this and
said you go to prison for stealing from
your own people that's what happened but
in the countries the large countries
none of this has taken place and while
on the subject of crime and punishment
who has been punished for the war in
Iraq no one
I mean at the very least the United
States should offer one person to be
tried at the Criminal Court and that
could be Dick Cheney he'd be a popular
choice as war criminal so laws that
supposedly apply to others do not apply
to the United States or its allies and
we're in a situation where it's become
virtually impossible for mainstream
parties and even some left groups and
left parties only the Italian parties
are saying withdrawal from NATO we don't
want to be part of a military alliance
the Labour Party in Britain isn't not
even Corbin podemos isn't saying we
should quit NATO so there are lots of
problems but this transition also offers
solutions and these solutions are in
flux
at the moment there are left futures
ahead we see them you know in small ways
in different parts of the world though
they've been defeats here and there but
I think that we are also on the eve of
change in some shape or form because the
only other choice that exists is that of
the extreme right which is much much
stronger than us all over Western Europe
and North America particularly in this
country so we have to do something we
have to organize we have to fight back
and on every possible level thank you
[Applause]
alright ladies and gentlemen thanks
thanks so much to our different
panelists who spoke we are going to do a
quick Q&A just a few questions here
we're gonna talk just a little bit right
okay then we'll take like three
questions but they need to come right to
the front right here yes
all right just while people are moving
around some quick comments I had a
question for you Chris about a
surveillance and what function you think
surveillance the surveillance state is
you know what function it's serving
particularly what Sun function it is
serving these are VR social movements
when your government watches you 24
hours a day which our government is
doing you cannot use the word Liberty
that is the relationship between a
master and a slave is that Chris folks
if you're leaving please you need to
respect that the conversation is
continuing so please keep your
conversation to outside the whole people
at the back pipe down the far end I
should say I really am only taking three
questions and they're not going to be
from three white men so
work it out amongst yourselves but I
don't see any women here the the problem
is that the corporate elites have
created a system through militarized
police the evisceration of civil
liberties wholesale surveillance and
this has already been completed in
marginal communities where rights have
essentially become privileges and
privileges as an arrant again going back
to errant once rights become privileges
in a society then they can be taken away
they have created the perfect system of
wholesale surveillance and oppression
within communities of color which have
been effectively demonized by a
corporate media in a political class and
the consequence is that when the rest of
the system the population becomes as
restive all of the mechanisms are in
place at the flick of a switch so that
we begin to suffer the excesses of power
that we are culpable for because we did
not stand up for poor people of color
when the Constitution was being shredded
in front of their face
a question for you Madea one of the
aspects of this evenings panel has been
this question of humanities peril
all this militarism all this capitalism
is putting humanity at peril you travel
I know it sounds sappy but I really
don't mean it I mean it in us in a in an
inspiring ly useful way where do you see
Humanity rebe being reclaimed or claimed
in the context of all of us
and you've been stories how do how do we
rebuild our humanity I see it in the
challenges that people on the ground are
making to the oppression if you take the
example of Israel the fact that
throughout the world there is this very
vibrant boycott divestment and sanctions
movement is very inspiring and when you
hear only Hillary Clinton's say that BDS
is evil and encourages students and
their campuses to fight against it I
think that just is going to inspire in
the fall a tremendous movement on our
campuses and I think our young people
are going to show us how they can stand
up against Hillary Clinton's bullying
Tariq I have a media question but before
before that I have a question about
Ireland I had the great pleasure of
being back in Ireland for the first time
in many many years recently on
assignment for that for the Nation
magazine and I was there for the
hundredth anniversary of the so-called
Easter Rising 1916 the first armed
rebellion event against colonial rule of
the 20th century I think and what was so
striking to me was they've been it's a
hundred years right so they've been many
anniversaries in every instance until
this one the main thrust of the debate
in Ireland anyway was whether the
uprising was justified whether the
civilian deaths could be justified
whether this had how long had this
delayed independence for this southern
state the Irish state had laid it on
very heavy and
the debate had taken place in a very far
I would say a very conservative part of
the spectrum politically this time the
complete opposite
most people claiming the legacy not just
of the rabat the rebels but of the left
flank of the rebels particularly the
james Connolly's those who talked about
socialism of the anti nationalism at
fighting Empire you saw a lot of focus
on the women rebels who are the ones at
the same time were nurses and doctors
but also snipers and fighters my
question to you is one of the things I
saw happening in Ireland that was
exciting was just about every
schoolchild had been asked to write
their own proclamation for 2016 and what
had been asked to consider what would
their Republic of the 21st century look
like I wonder to what extent you see
exercises like this happening in the
countries that you're talking about or
if you have any suggestions of how we
can go about really visualizing the
future that we want to make because
presumably we need to start making it
now rather than waiting for someone
handed down to us well the the Irish
situation the 1916 anniversary took
place at a time where Island is
confronting a huge economic crisis and
where the European Union has imposed on
it a set of laws which do not allow the
Irish to carry out any spending without
permission
from Brussels including on culture and
this is felt of course all over the
countries secondly the
European Union rules insist on
privatization which is what their
economists have been advising the Irish
the water privatization the defeat of it
by a mass popular movement brought about
the fall of the government which was
huge secondly a number of radical
left-wing socialist candidates have been
elected for the first time in Northern
Ireland to the Belfast Parliament a
group called people before profits two
of their main campaigners were elected
to Parliament likewise the water
campaigners and other radicals have been
elected into the parliament in Dublin
and are playing a very good role by
refusing to take sides in the old wars
between the Irish political parties oak
island has a very special history as you
know Laura and each country has to rely
and depend on its own history and the
precedents in these countries and bring
them back to life here of course you
know very few people talk about the
slave rebellions all of the groups of
small groups but important groups of
whites who help these rebellions in the
past in Britain no one ever talks about
the examples of the English revolution
after all England was the first country
to execute its monarchs I remember
saying this in Australia just as a
throwaway line and the whole audience
started applauding and then I remembered
that I don't think they heard what you
said I say it again our England was the
first kind of England was the first
country which decided after a trial to
execute the king and the French did it
later of course and then the Russians
followed
and in the United States I think that
event the English revolution played a
big part because a lot of the Puritans
who'd come to the States before being
English revolution did have certain
radical traditions many of them forgot
those but they existed and that must
have played a part in preventing those
who wanted the United States to become a
monarchy because there were some amongst
the founding fathers who were keen on
that and that was reduced so I think you
know to answer your question each
country has elements in its past which
are heroic as the 1916 Easter uprising
and they have to develop them it's a
good idea all right let's take some
questions from the audience I said I
would take three and I wouldn't take
them all from men so let's do one to
first three I'm just gonna have to shout
I'll restate your question it has to
have a question mark at the end yep
[Music]
so your question all right it's a mess a
good question what does the panel think
of the slogan drop Food Not Bombs air
lifts two people under siege in relation
to Syria Madea I think it's a great
slogan we were just in Congress this
week with those very signs and I agree
that we have to say to our government
that it is not doing its part to make
sure humanitarian aid gets to the
besieged communities in Syria and it
certainly is not doing its part to allow
Syrian refugees into this country we
should be taking in over a hundred
thousand the goal of ten thousand is
ridiculous and we've only taken in one
thousand three hundred which is shameful
all right can you do as well with the
question mark at the end yes
what are the parallels between the
prison industrial complex and the
military-industrial complex thank you
good sharp question Chris going to enter
any inner-city school and you can see
that these kids are being conditioned
for two routes both of which essentially
rip from their freedom and that is the
prison or the military those are the
options recruiters are all over poor
neighborhoods and when you are in the
school to Prison Pipeline you're
surrounded by guards you're going
through metal detectors increasingly in
charter schools you are disciplined as
if you were in the military and of
course discipline inside a prison
replicates discipline inside military
structures and so yes it's a very
important question because with the loss
of manufacturing jobs
the rise of surplus labor the staggering
amounts of unemployment 50% for black
youth higher if we count underemployment
they are being trained to either be
cannon fodder or locked in cages anybody
else want just comment on that no next
question we don't have one but come up
here we'll help you go for it what's
your question Oh
so the Constitution set up public banks
all right so the Constitution all right
we've got a recommendation for you thank
you what do you think about about
reconstituting the public banks and I
would encourage you to take a look at a
very good episode of the Laura Flanders
show where we talked about exactly that
and democratizing the Fed so so I agreed
that that's something that's absolutely
necessary in building a peace economy
and we have actually as Code Pink a new
peace economy program we have sign-up
sheets that's been going around here if
you haven't had a chance to see it
please come up after and sign up so we
can work together to build public banks
to build public institutions and to
build the kind of localized economy that
will take the power away from the
corporations Tariq let me get you to
wait to come in on this as I understand
it the Labor Party under Corbin has
actually pledged some public money to
these kinds of initiatives work of
cooperatives in particular yeah
they have done that but between pledging
them and winning an election and coming
to power who knows what's going to
happen you know one has to be realistic
about the cose the the pledges Corbin is
made some of them are very huge that's
going to be a big fight to realize the
railway system in the car
tree which is a very popular demand
supported by between sixty and eighty
percent of the population and this has
been the case for many decades he's the
first political leader who said we're
going to do it the EU is going to fight
him saying it challenges some of the
competition rules in the EU the
Conservative Party and half the Blair
rights in his own party so on every
single thing there's going to be a huge
struggle and if it's just left to
Parliament and debates in Parliament it
won't get through anything you have to
have big mass movements popular
movements from below like the movement
that finally elected him to be kept up
to maintain support without them I think
it's going to be difficult or what I
need to take a group conscience here we
had said three questions shall I take
three more all right three more come on
when Germany gives a bailout to Greece
is that added to the principle question
well it is and most of these bailouts
given to Greece they are not bailouts
its money given to Greece so they can
pay back the interest on what they
borrowed before very little of that
money actually goes to the Greek people
who are suffering real privations at the
moment it's I cannot even begin to
describe how awful the situation in
Greece is when the Greek people wanted
change 61% of them voted to break with
all these measures they strengthened
their government unfortunately their
government capitulated to the European
you quickly I'm not sure if anyone is in
the line wants to ask this question but
I want to make sure that we do get each
of you to respond just briefly to the
question of what is happening in Latin
America right now destabilization in
Argentina Venezuela Brazil we haven't
mentioned this so far but I don't want
to have the evening closed without
getting there well I think we have to
sort of associated phenomenon one is
that the State Department ie the United
States has been trying to weaken
destabilize the Bolivarian governments
the progressive governments in South
America ever since they came into office
so there is nothing new and they weren't
able to do it and one reason why they
are able to do it as the decline in the
price of basic commodities ie
oil in the case of Venezuela has meant a
huge crack economic crisis in that
country which they haven't been able to
tackle it's not easy I mean though some
of the good advice was rejected in
Argentina so you have now attempts to
constitutional attempts to topple Maduro
before his term is over a constitutional
coup against Dilma Rouseff in Brazil and
an electoral victory for a total and
complete row in Argentina Argentina is
well on the way to becoming the first
hedge-fund Republic in South America
thank you alright quick question from
you
just as capitalism emerged from
feudalism right now there are workers
producer cooperatives that are emerging
question the problem is the system and
the system is capitalism all the reforms
your question all the movements my
question is do you see that the approach
of workers produce your self-organized
cooperatives on the model of Mondragon
and
vast country that really this is the
future because it confronts and it deals
with the issue of this is all right
great which is capitalism question mark
capital it just a book of cooperatives
help so I think this has a lot to do
with the last question about the public
banks because you need public banks to
be able to give out loans to worker
cooperatives because the commercial
banks are not going to do that kind of
thing and you need worker cooperatives
to have decentralized power and I think
when I talked about a localized piece
economy that's what we're talking about
is new ways of organizing so thank you
for bringing that up and once again if
you want to work with us at code pink
come and talk to us
Jody Evans right here is in charge of
our local peace economy campaign and we
need more folks to work with us great
and I would just say exactly these kinds
of topics of worker democracy of
transformation of the workplace and of
relations of production and distribution
and consumption are the sorts of things
we talk about on a weekly basis on the
Laura Flanders show so check it out all
right the three of you come on up here
our our friend okay oh well the first
thing I want to say is in this society
right now a white male is not
necessarily white and they are not
necessarily male and I don't think the
white males that are here are the ones
that we are against so in the interest
of unity I want the white males to know
that they are equal to what I would have
to say now my other question is 90% of
my students are Pro Bernie Sanders I got
the feeling that he was written off yet
I've never seen Hillary Clinton as
threatened as she is right now
and she even just said that she would
consider Bernie Sanders as her vice
president so what I'm saying is what I'm
saying is why is there a feeling whether
you're pro or against Bernie Sanders
that he's to be sort of written off to
be in a position of power and control
even if you don't agree with everything
he says
all right good question about Bernie
come on your question and then we'll get
answers from our panelists I'm just
curious what we don't think about how do
we get beyond geopolitics of separation
and competition into like a unified
planetary synergy and like what is
beyond this paradigm of political
struggle on the global scale all right
and the last one yes this is on the
subject of surveillance
people talk about using encryption to
protect our data but the NSA has methods
of surveillance that you can encrypt
they have a grid of space satellites
with interferometry this 3-d
holographically scanner Holmes brains in
effect and my friend in the department
of fence works for them dr. Robert
Duncan comm has info from him
he claims they're spying on us and
they've attacked people the radiation we
want to know what we could do to get
this stopped and get people covering
this issue and NSA whistleblower William
Binney and Russell theis
support us and we have videos of them on
the site victims so three sort of macro
questions there one about what are we
writing off Bernie Sanders given what
sort of a threat he seems to be posing
to Hillary Clinton to what do we do to
get down to a more harmonically
convergent sphere and and plane and
three what do we do about the
possibility that we're being spied on
and let me address the issue of Bernie
Sanders because I I don't write Bernie
Sanders off in fact with Shama she and I
encouraged Bernie to run as an
independent and Shama now has a petition
up what's the what's that called Shama
it is it there's a petition she has up
calling on Bernie to run as an
independent
so no far from writing Sanders off I
think that both Shama and I were
concerned from the beginning that he
would be strangled by the Democratic
establishment as he has been and that we
have to begin to build and if you know
we are encouraging Sanders to revoke
given the fact that the election was
stolen from him revoke his commitment to
support Clinton and with his agenda and
the money that he's raised and the
enthusiasm that he's raised step outside
the system and begin to build a movement
so I'm not writing Sanders are following
up on that I think I was why reading The
Washington Post the other day and it had
a screaming headline that said the
majority of Millennials have a more
favorable view of socialism than
capitalism that is quite astounding and
that is thanks to Bernie Sanders so
Bernie Sanders has done something
amazing for a young generation that
treats this old curmudgeon like a rock
star and they are taking in what he said
and they are going to use it in
different ways and that is to build a
different system in this country so
nobody I don't think here is writing off
Bernie Sanders we say thank you Bernie
for the opening that you've given to a
lot of people especially the young
generation and let's be inspired by that
and hopeful that they are going to say
socialism is the way we want to go and
we're going to build it in a 21st
century that fits what we want in the
United States and that's very exciting
I think harmonic you know harmony and
convergence is left for Utah now I want
to say a few things about Bernie too
because the campaign's having a huge
impact globally people can't believe
what they are watching on the web not on
their television screens but certainly
on the web is these huge mobilizations
and it would be a big tragedy for the
United States if these mobilizations
simply disappeared once Hillary gets it
I think she has got it there's no point
in pretending she hasn't I mean if she
didn't I'd be delighted but I think she
has so the big question is you build a
movement an important movement a
democratic movement a movement which
talks about socialism about dealing with
the banks but we can't for the future
limit this movement to the electoral
cycle of US politics something needs to
be done and it it will happen if that's
what the kids want to happen and I note
that the young generation that today's
generation has no problem with Dinosaurs
either here you have Bernie or in
Britain where we have Jeremy Corbyn both
of them are virtually the same age and
that is not what's affecting people what
is attracting them is the ideas which
they are putting forward which many
people respond to question is how to
take these movements further as for the
synergy I mean look the the Bolivarian
in South America tried very hard and
while you Chavez was alive succeeded to
a certain extent when the oil prices
were right he said any government in
South America which wants to build a
health service which wants to build
cheap houses for workers and the poor
which wants to create doctors in its own
society there is a blank check here you
are go and do it and it thinks were
moving in that direction with various
bodies economic bodies being formed etc
that is now in a state of collapse
tragically but the ideas are still there
and people won't forget them that's the
important thing to remember lots of
people remember the good things that
happened and the good things that were
done and when the mood is right they
will come back to them and one of these
was to try and unite the South American
continent both against the big brother
in the north and in the south and they
may I mean Simon Bolivar couldn't do it
he said it's like plowing the sea but
Chavez got a few steps beyond believe on
that and they actually began to do it so
you know one one can't give up simply
because they're going through a bad
period
I just wanted to add one other thing
that Bernie Sanders has done it has
before Bernie Sanders been just
impossible for any leading candidates to
talk about Palestine in a way that is in
any way sympathetic and the fact that
Bernie Sanders has brought that up and
says that's going to be a fight in the
Democratic platform he's not gonna say
what a lot of us would like to say which
has caught off every cent to that
repressive apartheid regime he's gonna
say we want an even-handed approach but
you know that is miles of ahead of what
we have had final comment Chris I think
the power of Sanders is that he gave or
verbalized the reality around us in a
way that other politicians including
Barack Obama have not done economic
inequality that's a fact it's a fact
that most Americans
can see every day and that is a huge
breakthrough on the other hand I think
Sanders and his voting record backs this
up doesn't understand that you cannot be
a socialist unless you are an
anti-imperialist that imperialism is the
mechanism that creates centralized
control that serves the dictates of
Empire at the expense of the citizenry
and that it is that not just militarism
in terms of as Madea pointed out that is
financially disembowelling the country
but it is also and both parties are
guilty of this creating an ideology one
where we deify the military we dfi
systems of internal security and the
consequence of that is the kind of proto
fascism that we are seeing now in Trump
rallies and I'm looking for a candidate
that and of course it's political
suicide as George McGovern found out or
earlier Henry Wallace found out but I'm
looking for a radical candidate that
understands that the first step on the
road to socialism is the destruction of
American imperialism Chris Hedges Medea
Benjamin tariq Ali thank you all three
[Applause]
have a great forum everybody see you
tomorrow bright and early